PROFESSOR: I don't have
anything very structured,
but I just want to get
the conversation going.
The first question I
have for you guys is,
tell me about a time you
had to problem solve.
So I want you to talk to
the person next to you
and discuss when you had
a problem solve today.
[SIDE CONVERSATIONS]
Girld who--
AUDIENCE: Build.
PROFESSOR: Do I
have any volunteers
for some good examples?
How about on the rest
where-- OK, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: What'd you do to--
AUDIENCE: Well you have to
figure out where exactly you
went wrong so you can fix it.
PROFESSOR: Nice.
What about you?
AUDIENCE: It's not very
like an intricate problem,
but everybody in my
family has an iPhone.
We all take each other's
chargers if we lose our own.
So to solve that
problem I got a Sharpie
and I drew a heart
on my charger.
PROFESSOR: Oh, nice.
AUDIENCE: And I
knew this is mine.
And I couldn't take it anymore.
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: That's a good idea.
Anyone else?
Anyone-- how about for the
raspberry pie activity?
Did everything work flawlessly?
AUDIENCE: Probably not.
PROFESSOR: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: If I brought
that picture of the camera
up on the camera it was
upside down and backwards.
We figured out how to
flip it and make it right.
PROFESSOR: Oh, nice.
Was it hard figuring out where
to put that line of code?
AUDIENCE: Kind of.
We figured out which section
was brought up on the camera
and which section was
brought on the computer
and put it in the right one.
PROFESSOR: Good.
How about for processing?
Any good examples?
Yeah, in the back.
AUDIENCE: I had to figure
out what the camera was
trying to see, so--
PROFESSOR: How'd
you figure that out?
AUDIENCE: Well, [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Great.
My next question is,
how would you improve
the camera you built today?
So this time turn to someone
behind you or in front of you,
and tell them what you
would do differently.
[SIDE CONVERSATIONS]
PROFESSOR: Girls who--
AUDIENCE: Build.
PROFESSOR: Do I have any
volunteers from the second row?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: We said that we'd
make the camera more durable,
because ours broke
and so did theirs.
Like the plastic part
where you hold it together.
PROFESSOR: Nice.
What kind of material do
you think you would use?
AUDIENCE: We like metal
or a better plastic.
PROFESSOR: Did any of you
guys play with Alex's lenses?
Did you see how
protective they were?
And a lot of professional
photographers,
they break them all the time.
So-- yeah there are ways
to make it more structured
and prevent it from breaking.
Any other ideas
besides the case?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: The speed.
It would take a photo
a couple seconds
after you pressed the button.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So it would be
a lot easier to photos
if the moment you see
the image you want,
if you took the photo it would
get that exact moment instead
of like two seconds
after of something.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
That's a really good point.
Anyone else?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I tried to
make it so that when
you are zooming the
camera around and looking
at the image on
the screen it moves
more smoothly, so that it's not
jerky images as you're moving.
PROFESSOR: Do you guys
remember how in the code
it said-- you had code
for displaying that image,
and then you had code for
displaying the-- or capturing
the picture that you took
when you pressed the button?
So when you have that code
for capturing the image,
when it's displaying
on the screen
it's actually taking that image
and then displaying it to you.
So that's a lot of
work for a computer
to do versus just-- I
think Gavin actually
had looked at that.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I was trying to make it faster.
PROFESSOR: What were your ideas?
What would you have done?
AUDIENCE: So there's a
way that you can just
write some memory
instead of-- so there's
different types of memory.
There's RAM versus your
permanent storage on the SD
card.
The SD card is a lot slower.
So you can save it
into your local memory
and cache it, and
then throw that one
the screen without interacting
with the file system.
That should be faster.
But I didn't get to it.
PROFESSOR: Sweet.
The volunteers are thinking
about this stuff, too.
The last question
I have for you is,
tell me about an
Instagram filter
that you changed from the
original instructions.
So this time turn to
someone next to you,
but someone different that
you haven't talked to yet.
[SIDE CONVERSATIONS]
Girls who--
AUDIENCE: Build.
PROFESSOR: OK.
How about from the third row.
What did you guys change
with your filters?
Any volunteers?
Did you guys just keep it
the same the whole time?
No?
What'd you do?
AUDIENCE: Oh--
AUDIENCE: Wait.
PROFESSOR: Oh.
You can both go.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
I did one where
you could click it,
and then I just put
on the [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Oh, nice.
Did anyone else do the
image effects change?
Oh, nice.
One person back there.
What about from over here?
What did you guys do with
the Instagram filters?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Well, [INAUDIBLE]
the original instructions.
We changed the colors
on the first one
from a red-ish, greenish
color to a lavender.
PROFESSOR: Oh, neat.
Cool.
The RGB values?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Yeah?
You, too?
AUDIENCE: I messed with
the turn everything
except the color you clicked
on into grayscale one
to turn it into--
turn just the color
you clicked on into black.
PROFESSOR: Oh, nice.
Those are all
really great ideas.
So this concludes the program.
I hope you guys had
a wonderful time
and learned about things
that you wouldn't normally
think about when you
think of computer coding
and engineering.
There were a ton of people-- all
the volunteers in the morning,
and then the ones
in the afternoon,
and our keynote speakers.
So they are in the
room next door,
but let's give them a round of
applause so they can hear you.
[APPLAUSE]
And you guys probably caught
on to this, but most of us
work at MIT Lincoln Laboratory.
I do ocean robotics there.
And I hope you got a chance
to talk to your volunteers
and hear about what
they do at the lab.
We do all sorts of things.
And SolidWorks also
sponsored this.
And MIT OpenCourseWare-- have
any of you guys heard of that?
Raise your hand if you have.
Oh, not too many of you.
Good.
So MIT OpenCourseWare
is online curriculum.
So if you guys want
to get this code,
we're publishing it online
so you can play more with it
and get the software and
all the instructions.
We also have a curriculum
and wearable technology.
So you can check that out, too.
And all this information will
be sent to you in an e-mail.
And we also have
a Facebook page,
it's just Girls Who Build,
and a Twitter account.
And I'll be posting all
the material and photos
from this workshop
on those websites.
So with that, I have a bunch
of fun demos for you guys.
We have 3D scanning,
and photogrammetry,
and a light field camera
in the research area.
So you can rotate
around the stations
and ask questions and
talk to the volunteers.
We also have the
computer still set up,
so you have a little bit
of time to keep playing
with the code and the cameras.
So in conclusion, thank
you all for coming.
And feel free to come
up to me and ask me
more about camera technology.
We'd happy to tell you about
other fun projects you can do.
Thank you, guys.
[APPLAUSE]